yes because the lights go out on his
Premiership Boris Johnson wants you to
remember his plan for keeping them on
for the country on a valedictory visit
to seizewell proposed site of a new
nuclear power station that could power 6
million homes he'd hoped to announce six
billion pounds of government funding but
that like much else remains unfinished
business
that's why we're putting 700 million
pounds into the deal just part of the
1.7 billion pounds of government funding
available for developing a large-scale
nuclear project to final investment
stage FID in this Parliament and
in the course of the next few weeks I am
absolutely confident that it will get
over the line there are currently five
operational nuclear sites in the UK with
three more proposed and one under
construction right now those reactors
provide around 15 of the UK's energy
wind power around 13 while over half
comes from gas
the next prime minister's more immediate
inheritance is an energy crisis
engulfing homes and businesses like this
Birmingham metal spinner facing massive
increases to its fixed power costs
you're looking at from 100 and maybe 20
30k to at least 618k
that's a and that's a big increase
it is it is clear that we're expecting
that the government will step in and do
something to cap
um or reduce this imminent increase
because we cannot afford to have certain
increase the biggest challenge for
companies like this isn't about energy
Supply not yet anyway it's about
affordability because wherever the power
that's running that machine is generated
in a nuclear reactor or in a wind
turbine the price is being set by gas
and that is why bills are soaring and
British business is desperate to hear
what support if any the new government
will bring
the future of British energy is
renewable as well as nuclear the largest
offshore wind farm in the world off the
Yorkshire coast and the largest in
Scotland both open this month but a full
transition away from gas and fossil
fuels to permanently lower bills will
take decades how we get through the next
year or two is no longer Boris Johnson's
problem
Paul Kelso Sky News